I thought I was gonna sneeze hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to Super Mario maker I'm
still playing the hard levels' but this
one isn't too hard and to make things
more interesting I'm actually putting
forward a challenge for every time that
I curse from damned to [ __ ] every time
that I curse I will donate another
hundred dollars to charity so I'm gonna
try to get through this without cursing
as much as possible so that I control
the white-hot burning rage inside of my
soul so Matt keep track for me and the
charity will be you guys's choice so
decide in the comments down below and
i'll donate maybe i'll donate a hundred
here and there or maybe i'll donate all
the one but write in the comments if you
have a favorite charity of yours that
you want the donations to go to so let's
get on and let's hope i don't curse too
much but at the same time kind of do
because that's how the good is gonna
happen so let's play the game this one
has a thirteen percent clear rate so it
shouldn't be oh look at me
oh it give me a star oh this is off to a
great start because that means that i'm
gonna do relatively okay okay oh oh
that's cool
oh whoops oh dang it oh I wasn't
supposed to do that was I Oh poopy oh no
wait maybe oh I get it
ah maybe I was supposed to take that
with me I'm not visible hello thank you
okay so this is interesting because I've
never actually played like the original
NES Legend of Zelda are the only
actually true
hello oh I need you oh I need you no no
oh oh god oh god yes Oh can't believe I
did that
I had no idea what I'm doing yeah so
anyway I haven't played any of the old
Zelda games
oh this was
oh there was no point to this
oh that was just an easter egg oh thank
you
so I'm gonna need you hey hey cut son of
a [ __ ] I'm not linked anymore oh I'm
not know anyway so I'm gonna need you
guys to point out if there's something
here that I'm missing because it's got
to be something I'm missing over here
can I have another please one more thank
you good there we go oh man have I been
cursing this whole time I just said damn
I just a gimmick in God stop okay I'm
okay thank you thank you for your
concern everybody I'm doing okay matt is
the counter been running you already I
didn't even think about it it's my
challenge and I didn't even think about
it
oh man I'm gonna do so much good so much
good for the whole purpled oh but I'm
not gonna do so much good for my soul if
I end up dying over here a million times
oh hey oh that's good oh god damn oh
that's not good either fine I get it
it's the one that the freaking arrow is
going to I should have known it should
have been incredibly obvious but I'm
horrendous ly stupid this is a bud okay
dammit dammit gosh dingus damn it no no
there we go
Oh how's that gonna help me yeah Oh
screw Oh screw you stupid game oh now
that's gonna be Oh No how am I gonna Oh
Oh No okay well I can do this oh I can't
do this here Oh piss can I have that
with me can I just okay there we go mmm
oh god oh god oh there we go
okay everything's fine why am i so
panicked about this I've been saying
curse words again because I have no idea
now I got admit that this one actually
is pretty creative because I haven't
seen much like this in a long time most
of the Mario maker levels that I play
are recommended to me by you guys and
they're absolutely terrible not not
terrible I guess goddamn oh yeah I got
you terrible in the sense that they make
me I said it again I said it again dang
it thing is dang it why don't I go back
to my flabbergast errs oh well thank you
flabbergast Rose is my frumble dunks all
my different words oh thank you I had no
idea that was gonna happen
hmm don't hit me
oh thank you well that would have been
easy to know if I would have just got
into mushroom over there but I'm I'm
kind of doubtful because this is 11
percent clear rate which isn't like the
highest in the world
oh wait oh hi
whoa that's that's that was a little
unusual I didn't know I did not suspect
that oh okay then all right then I got
I'm it there's a lot of creativity going
on here where I got these levels they
were in the suggestion there's this
website that allows you to bookmark them
and I get it Ryan to do this because
we're gonna still use my mooch but he
looked at yeah stab bad how am I
supposed to get there god I'm not
supposed to get there so
huh
what happened what the hell is that I've
no idea what went on oh that's amazing
oh that's even more amazing that seems
like a lot of coincidence but I'm gonna
count it as skill because I've got
nothing better to do with my time than
take credit for other people's
accomplishments okay well what's over
here so if I got there in time for a pal
block to happen with that a Venice
secret area that I could have gone to so
weird oh hey oh well that was quick
okay I guess we're fine then everybody
go home
nothing to panic about you okay she'll
hit god damn it damn it damn it
that better be [ __ ] it that better have
been close enough okay yay oh boy I'm
Zelda I was Zelda the whole time Oh
okay yeah okay that did nothing that was
not what I was supposed to do
ah crap this isn't what I was supposed
to do maybe I'm supposed to go back I
have no idea I'm really cocking it up
damn it god damn it there goes Elda gosh
dingus damn it I am NOT no how about now
that's a whole lot of new ah dammit
that's what I was supposed to do I'm a
dinger I'm a dinger dang it oh man oh
god no oh no I can't lose here come so
far
come on do it again do it again for me
do it again for daddy
don't come again flanked flanger put a
fudgesicle what a stigma ah come on
how quick can I make that I'm doing the
best I can do not Oh God
oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh okay we got this
we rollin we rollin we got this yeah
here we go oh god oh god they slow me
down
ah yes okay I did it
yeah all right so what does that mean
this is a long-ass level I didn't even
know the lovers could be this long Mario
maker it's crazy
okay where's the suit moveable bit all
right I need that reasons oh hello
bah ah I could have done that way better
dang nabbit flooded signals okay so that
one wasn't particularly hard but that
was just like a warm-up to get back into
the swing of things because they're
gonna get harder after that and I
apologize I'm still sick so I need you
suck down another cough drop I'm alright
so we're gonna move on to something a
little bit more difficult this is about
twice as difficult only a seven point
eight three clear rate so if I can get
this one without cursing that would
probably oh god oh god oh god oh why oh
Jesus
Oh Christmas crackers Oh ding is to come
Oh fudgsicles ah ok I went in that with
a blind panic it was a nice relaxing
game with the Zelda level but there was
no need for that to be of that
significance can I have this dang it can
you pick him up you can pick him up in
Mario in Mario World can't you I love
that music by the way reminds me of so
many things
boink yeah you picking him up so let me
let me just see yeah probably not the
best idea to do this but I'm and I just
wanna see what's in here
yes oh this is so convenient this is
gonna help me in so many ways don't
don't ah god damn it I just I just had
it I lost in bulk I lost everything
why what did you do oh my god oh holy
crap crap doesn't count by the way is
that very clear something up there that
I can get new ok alright moving on
moving forward
dingus damn frag nabbit frickle Dickel
dick doesn't count does dick count Matt
does dick count how many times I say
dick dang it
that ridiculous dick diction cow
hey oh no no no no I can get it I can
get this I can just nope
ah this walls maybe if I D spawn it if I
go back okay maybe I can respawn it
that'll work
always works know what I just peeked my
head and then changed my mind very
rapidly okay
says good yes I have maroush I got me
you yes please thank you goodbye sirs
goodbye use okay never mind then I'll
just carry on my way
sorry okay how about a little bit of
this
yeah oh crap huh
so if I do this oh okay I get loot thank
you going on my way now
I think that's where I came out of the
pipe this is really weird because dang
it dang it that was a long way to go
with that to [ __ ] up on me oh god um
frak Frick fudge fudge sickles I can do
this
Peregrin oh I got Plus try not to say is
because I didn't know if this counted
and I think this count now piss doesn't
count
fizzes in the curse word you can say
piss on TV probably maybe I don't know I
got damnit I lose it again so bad so
Taylor god dammit why I'm in a rush now
yeah right blow them all up their short
lives have been ended robbed away from
them alright thank you
okay let's take this again I was not
well oopsies
oopsie doops he's hello okay goodbye
sorry to interrupt my bad alright try
this again without a little bit a little
bit less stupid oh just take that bomb
I've always been worried about that you
know Yosh your digestive system probably
whoa what your digestive system probably
doesn't much allow for the digestion of
horrible bombs that are gonna blow up a
little bit later like that episode of
Spongebob which is amazing one of my
favorites old spongebob is obviously the
best okay BRB well I'm not not BRB buddy
oh god why damn it oh [ __ ] I still had
the star why did I still have the star
what a bunch of baloney ah [ __ ] alright
keep together I can do this yeah so
smooth so skilled so already I don't
need it ah there's one thing the mark of
our doesn't need it's a crutch to make
up for my incredible lack of skill my my
astonishing lack of skill really it's
it's it's tremendous in a way I don't
know what that sound is exactly
triggering probably bad stuff point
thank you
get this could mush get that can appear
Oh fudgsicles ah god dude Yosh Yosh dude
bro come on keep it together man
there's no need okay you can't eat them
yeah oh I forgot man there's so many
rules that I
overlook okay so this time I won't be
such of a speed demon and I won't screw
myself over screw doesn't count
no one count screw Matt don't count
screw screw doesn't count
you know don't count reading thank you
thank you thank you
I could have spun jump what is that what
is that horrible monstrosity ah good
thing it's gone forever all right okay
flying chumps these guys is no problem
man that one level that Aaron played was
just nuts you guys know the one that I'm
dying about one of the most recent
episodes of Mario maker it was just
insanity through and through oh who can
these blow those up yeah blow them up
you mad oh how about a checkpoint
thank you I don't know how to get
through here with fire maybe if I could
get it maybe okay I'll be right back
absolutely not that was a big negatory
on that one at least I got a checkpoint
that's good for me and somehow I'm gonna
be able to make those blue blocks go
away don't know how oh god why why have
you done this why have you forsaken me
ah God no my Yosh I'll never get him
back oh well time to long forget about
him time to lose to God why would I not
lose to because ding-dang-dong gonna do
enough fridge fridge door okay well I
don't even get a fire oh man I had a yo
[ __ ] a fire how am I gonna get through
this was just my crappy maybe they'll
maybe that fine maybe that fine his way
up maybe you do maybe do do it my dough
if my dough
it might dough where does this go
where's this go please tell me it goes
to the yosh please tell me I'm not
wasting my time but yeah that was stupid
of me I should have just normal jumped
well this is counterproductive I hope
this goes somewhere good it didn't okay
yep
haha man Higgins
crap I'm gonna get this okay here we go
how indie this is this just unfair
unfair Oh Andy mmm I'm small again
well I'm exactly where I was when I lost
my Yosh so that's okay
how do I uh how am I supposed to deal
with this uh-huh uh-huh deal with that
I'm gonna dad no matter
oh I should go under him that would be
better let's go under him that would be
much much more bet sir I ain't gonna let
this beat me I'm not gonna let this be
me there's no way whoo-hee how's it go
in there friend Oh how's it goin there
buddy boo
whee oh god damn it I keep forgetting
about the spikes up there but a bunch of
Asatru
hmm no wow that guy was not gonna let it
beat me a mushroom
okay here we go come at me bro oh yeah
you nearly got me with that one
I felt so threatened trust me you'll
really almost had me
this guy's gonna come speeding out of
nowhere
if you wonder / yes oh I don't even need
you oh I'm a master I don't know where
I'm going with this one to disaster I
imagine that's the thing the only thing
I'm a master of what is what am I
supposed to be jumping here is there
some illusion to some more difficulty
happening here that I'm not aware of
because it seems to be suggesting that I
should be terrible at this okay good
glad that was taken care of thank you
dammit I probably needed that there's
gonna be something here somewhere
somewhere there we go that's what
daddy's talking about again don't don't
call me daddy yeah yeah there we go hey
okay go down whoop and get that booty
shaking quick oh oh damn it damn it damn
it damn it damn it damn it damn it
whoa damn it I'm speeding I'm a speed
demon oh look at me go I ain't even
stopping for know about it for no reason
no reason why okay here we go
that did not go where I thought it was
gonna go that is terrifying oh that is
scary oh that's so scary oh I'm going in
oh god I'm not going in
oh yeah it was an illusion it was a
trick who's a Trixie trick how much
would you be able to get where I'm for
to get I don't understand this at all oh
my god whoa maybe I just didn't do it
hard enough cuz that is how it happened
here oh it gives pals I just know that I
should have known that how did I not
know that hey thank you I'm going up
away now yes
haha I did it Matt what's the final Oh
oh gosh that's a lot well I'm gonna
donate 3,700 charity of your choice so
thanks everybody so much for watching
I'm gonna do this again in the next
couple things I'm gonna be recording
yourself thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye this like might
be a bad idea